President Trump is leaving it up to
White House chief of staff John Kelly to
decide whether mr. Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner will get a final security
clearance the Washington Post reports
the Justice Department had alerted the
White House two weeks ago the ongoing
issues in Kushner security investigation
Kushner only has an interim clearance
that still gives him access to
top-secret and sensitive information as
president mr. Trump can give his
son-in-law a high-level security
clearance if the background
investigation goes on for more on the
developments in Washington we turn now
to a Nepal mer senior Washington
correspondent for Politico and co-author
of politico's playbook newsletter which
I read every morning Hannah good morning
good morning let's talk about this
latest turn in the events how much
pressure is now on Paul mana for given
the breadth of these indictments I mean
I think what you saw this week was
really the escalation on Paul Manafort
broader bail are getting closer every
week kind of the pieces are falling into
place 60 million dollars scheme that
he's a you know that they're accusing
him of this is one of his closest
advisors who's now pleading guilty so
the pressure is definitely ramping up so
what exactly do you think the Gates gets
this gaits plea gets Muller and where
does that point him now beyond mana Ford
I think we're still good and going to
figure that out one of the things about
the special prosecutor probe has been
how secret and they've been clamped down
on information we have been surprised
several times about where this is going
who's pleading guilty when they're
pleading guilty but it certainly also
gets him a step closer to president
Trump this was somebody who was deputy
campaign chairman of the Trump campaign
clearly on in the know at the highest
levels of what was happening there we
have a sense of how concerned the White
House is about this I mean I think they
have continued to say we are not a part
of this as you can tell this is
happening before the presidency started
but you have to look at where this is
going and it's clearly coming closer and
closer towards the white house towards
potentially Jared Kushner a lot of
people that have been questioned are
still working in this White House let's
talk about the issue of school the
school shooting in Florida and the
repercussions from that press
Trump has been in what the White House
is calling a listening phase on
developing gun safety measures is there
a real potential here for meaningful
legislation on the issue I think I'm a
real pessimist on this I've been
covering the gun lobby and gun reform
lobby for over ten years
it is very difficult to thread the
needle here certainly on smaller issues
maybe banding bump stocks meant closing
mental health care you know mental
health issues you could see something
happen but this concept of what the
president has been pushing on guns for
teachers is a non-starter for almost all
Democrats and a lot of Republicans well
the president clearly thinks his base is
in one place on the gun issue but then
what we're seeing in Florida is you have
a Republican governor who's actually
maybe open to some reforms does that
give you any inkling of whether the
dynamics may be changing for 2018 I
think that's gonna be the real big tell
here right a lot of people I think say
oh then are expens a lot of money and
that's why they control this I don't I
don't believe that to be true I think if
you actually look at it it's because
they win elections because they are able
to turn out this base and that if you
see the gun control I'll be able to flip
some of these seats and you make this an
issue all of a sudden their power
crumbles is there any indication of the
reaction from students in Florida who
are leading these marches is in any way
shifting this debate significantly i
think it's compelling and clearly it's
something that keeps it of mind one of
the biggest issues has been there's been
unfortunately a series of these kind of
mass shootings at schools and it Peaks
the you know all of us in the news us
we're covering it Congress is talking
about it but then nothing happens and
we've seen that time after time there is
another looming issue that needs to be
dealt with and that is the fate of the
dreamers and daca from the perspective
of the hill is there anything that is
actually going to be done in terms of a
legislative solution here I think right
now the month to watch is the end of
March it is going to be the next time
that the government has a funding fight
and that's really where you could see
the power of the purse come into play
unfortunately the dynamics have not
shifted so this kind of intentional how
are they going to deal with the border
wall how are they going to deal with
these young immigrants has not been
resolved all right a lot of unanswered
questions are in a palmer thank you very
much